you know people when I said the first
night this team is
cooked they were cooked and they still
are they're not going to make the
playoffs you know what happened was
Steph went crazy in game seven against
the Kings and that's the only reason
they beat the Kings the Kings had a
better team the problem with the
Warriors and I said it three years ago I
says if these young guys can't play
they're done that was wisman kaminga you
have two top five picks five or six
picks
they have to come in and be able to
contribute those guys have not
contributed I still have a little hope
for kaminga I thought he'd be further
along don't you think he's playing with
a lot more confidence now he's playing
with a lot more confidence but now it's
he they really it's too late now they
should have been doing the last couple
years because Dre's not the same Clay's
not the same and Steph can't explode he
can't be consistent of his age to cover
up all their weaknesses they have no
size and you know everybody's like they
were losing when Dre was there but like
I say they got away last year because
Steph went crazy in game seven and
people like well the Warriors this I
said man the Warriors are not the
same they pass their Prime and like I
say it w wisman was the key when you get
the number two pick in the draft he's
got to play because he's he's on another
team now because of their shooting
ability and their experience I'm I'm not
going to count them out well they're not
the same shooter yeah yeah they're not
the same shooter but listen like you
know we talking about consistency all in
these four or five games where these
guys can go crazy because there're only
two spots out of out of number eight
yeah but that but they're not I'm just
saying listen go like a four five game
winning spre it it doesn't matter
they're not contenders they can they you
go there's a difference between a
playoff team and a contender well
they're not a contender okay there go I
I might I might have to put you in that
I'm moving towards that yeah I wouldn't
want to play him in the playoffs let me
tell you something I and you guys like I
tell you one thing I know about old
people they just get older they don't
get better and sports are a young
people's game and Clay as much as I love
clay he's passed his prime same thing
with Dre and uh that's why they're G to
be streaky and Steph used to could cover
it up but he can't anymore because he's
starting to wear down like I say it it
was it was really those young guys I'm
not going to count them out
yeah